la passion du cinéma pour chacun d'entre
nous ça commence ici dans une salle
remplie de fauteuils rouges puis du
silence et des gens qui rentrent
s'installe et attendre que le projecteur
semer tente
[Musique]
et c'est le noir
la magie opère l'histoire commence
[Musique]
mais les salles de cinéma sont elles les
mêmes partout j'ai décidé d'aller en
inde le territoire où l'on fabrique le
plus de films
le pays aux 14 millions de spectateurs
par jour et aux douze mille salles elle
aussi pleine de fauteuils rouges et de
films inenvisageable ailleurs que la
barre une bonne raison de faire un
voyage inédit à travers les toiles de
l'inde
bienvenue à fismes city la ville du
carton-pâte la ville où l'on limite ce
qui s'apparente à du rêve
c'est ici que slumdog millionaire de
danny boyle s'achève et c'est ici que
pour moi tout commence
ici que tous les jours des milliers
d'enfants et d'adolescents arrive
avec une seule idée en tête devenir une
star de cinéma à n'importe quel prix
mais qu'arrive-t-il à cette génération
qui quittent famille et terre natale
pour embrasser un fantasme
la réponse est simple et très réel
drogue mendicité prostitution depuis 13
ans l'association sahati accueille les
enfants et les adolescents des rues
parler de la pratique du cinéma en inde
ça commence donc par parler d'eux par
parler avec eux de cinéma
j'adore regarder des films pourquoi ça
nous montre les problèmes de la vie
il y a des tas d'exemples on apprend des
choses
c'est vrai que ça fait réfléchir et puis
aussi
ça nous montre comment exploiter les
gens des techniques de pickpockets de
racket c'est cool
c'est déjà arrivé que des potes à moi
pense à cela après avoir vu un film est
reproduit ces comportements dans la
vraie vie
en fait être acteur c'est fascinant pour
ça parce qu'on peut tout se permettre
tout faire
par exemple comment aguicher une fille
l'amour quoi comment tomber amoureux
d'une fille ça me plaît bien ça aussi et
puis on peut gagner plein de pognon
voici à chaque méthode c'est le plus
grand directeur photo du cinéma indien
on l'a fait venir ici pour parler avec
vous de cinéma je voudrais savoir qui
veut faire du cinéma ici
moi je veux être acteur
moi aussi j'étais un enfant rebelle et
j'ai aussi quitter ma famille pour venir
dans la ville du cinéma iifa j'étais
fasciné par les enfants qui tournaient
dans les films je voulais faire comme
eux
mon premier travail quand je suis arrivé
de dellys était de vendre des oeufs durs
à peine il
travaillait pour quelqu'un et je gagnais
de roupies par jour
moi je voulais absolument aller dans
l'industrie du film et devenir acteur
alors je me suis rendu dans un studio et
j'ai commencé par travailler à la
cantine
ensuite j'ai été techniciens décorateurs
assistant lumière j'ai tout fait et dix
neuf ans j'ai finalement fini directeur
photo
si vous voulez vraiment très dans cette
industrie
il faut dire que vous pouvez travailler
dans n'importe quel secteur là où
l'opportunité se présente
et le destin il a rien à voir là dedans
la bonne étoile existe mais il faut
travailler pour forcer le destin
avez vous devez juré de ne plus vous
droguer à partir d'aujourd'hui on a tous
arrêtés très bien
donne moi ton numéro et tu me fais
rentrer par tous d'un malin toi
[Musique]
visage incroyable figure imposante et
chapeau toujours vissé sur la tête ou
presque à 62 ans ashok mehta a éclairé
film et plus de 60 films après un bond
de shay l'homme parle du cinéma de son
pays
que pensez-vous de l'impact qu'a le
cinéma sur les gens ici
le cinéma c'est un bon outil de
communication est fait mais gaulle alors
c'est pour cela qu'il faut que nous
fassions de bons films que nous
utilisions cet outil à bon escient parce
que le spectateur il voit toujours un
intérêt mais ce qui nous manque ici ce
sont de bons auteurs nous n'en avons pas
et il devient urgent d'améliorer cela
les spectateurs ici veulent uniquement
être divertis mais n'y at il pas un
moyen de le faire tout en les faisant
réfléchir
ce sont de grands consommateurs de films
mais hélas il ne mange pas toujours de
la qualité jambes c'est comme aller chez
mcdonald's mcd en fait des films fast
food et oui c'est ça on ne va pas
toujours dans un bon restaurant où on
passe une commande et où on attend
d'être servi on veut manger vite et
c'est un problème car nos films en
pâtissent
effectivement il est peut-être temps
pour bollywood de changer sa recette
d'autant que si les années précédentes
ont fabriqué plus de 900 films par an
soit cinq fois plus que la france cette
année les studios affiche une baisse de
30% la principale raison la
multiplication des chaînes de télévision
serait ce la fin des films d'amour qui
dépasse allègrement les 3 heures
les balèzes synchronisée dégoulinant de
dorures est ce la crise à bollywood pas
si évident car malgré une réduction des
coûts dans les studios on continue de
chanter et de danser distraire est
semble-t-il la priorité de ce cinéma
[Musique]
ok
me voici devant le marathon man dire au
centre de la mégapole tentaculaire se
dresse un cinéma art déco sublime
sa particularité
projeté le même film depuis 15 ans du
jamais vu c'est le film indien par
excellence dont le titre parle de lui
même l'amant emmènera la mariée
en résumé une riche héroïne tombe
amoureuse d'un homme qui ne lui est pas
destiné ça c'est pour le g à côté on
chante on danse et on guette shah rukh
khan le demi dieu ici depuis 20 ans
[Musique]
vous êtes déjà venu voir ce film ça fait
douze ou quinze fois
moi c'est la cinquième fois
et à chaque fois je ne vois que ma star
shah rukh khan d'ailleurs vous avez la
même coupe de cheveux que lui ça va moi
ça fait 8 ou 10 fois que je le vois pas
ce que j'aime bien rire et pleurer
j'adore les histoires d'amour pour moi
ces films c'est un vrai moment d'évasion
les chansons sont très très belle
qu'est ce qui vous plaît tant
les paysages sont beaux le héros est
parfait
pour 50 copies vous assistez à trois
heures trente de spectacle
ce cinéma très premier degré est une
activité nationale très sérieuse en main
et pour vous montrer à quel point on ne
rigole pas avec ça l'hymne national
indien retenti avant chaque séance et
tout le monde se lève
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment vous appelez-vous jack jérôme
baroé jivan marot et vous êtes le
projectionniste du cinéma oui
et depuis combien de temps ça fait 40
ans
et le marathon man dire existe depuis 55
là je suis en train de marquer le film
pour le changement de bobine il ne faut
pas que le public se rende compte qu'il
y ait un changement de bobine
[Musique]
on vous a déjà dit que vous ressembliez
à charlie chaplin à c'est le plus beau
compliment que l'on puisse me faire on
me l'a jamais dit en plus vous me
comparer un artiste est de surcroît un
artiste étranger vraiment j'apprécie je
m'en souviendrai toute ma vie
c'est quoi ça jazz band à ce camp les
spectateurs sont hystériques ou pas
contents et déchire les fauteuils c'est
le premier truc qu'ils ont sous la main
pour passer leurs nerfs
le cinéma ici c'est vraiment sacré faut
pas rigoler avec ça
film soit depuis 15 ans elle affiche
la première chose qui explique le succès
de ce film ce sont les chansons et la
musique par les gens adorent ça la
deuxième chose c'est le prix de la place
qui est deux fois moins cher car c'est
un vieux film
mais ce qui fait vraiment le succès de
ce film c'est qu'il s'adresse à tout le
monde c'est universel
dans ce film il n'est question que
d'amour
et pourtant à aucun moment les acteurs
ne se disent je t'aime
alors qu'ils s'aiment à la folie il n'y
a pas vraiment d'histoire et pendant
3h30 le public ne bouge pas d'un poil
pendant tout le film on se demande
qu'est ce qui va se passer
le temps passait finalement les deux
héros se retrouve à part ça il n'y a
rien
film alors il ya 30 jours dans un mois
deux mois dans l'année ça fait quinze
ans que ce film est ici donc 5400 fois
y at il une scène qui représente
parfaitement le film il y en a une
louche à maracana trouve un pigeon mort
alors pour le soigner il applique la
terre du champ sur sa blessure et
l'oiseau ressuscité s'envole
dans ce film on sait de la terre qui
nous nourrit c'est ça le pouvoir réel
qu'à la terre de notre pays elle guérit
et porteuse de vie ce film c'est la
quintessence de notre pays c'est le
message du fil c'est ce que véhiculent
les films de bollywood et les gens
adorent ces histoires le cinéma c'est
comme un fantasme pour eux c'est un
endroit où l'on se vide de toutes les
tensions du quotidien et ça évite aussi
que les gens se drogue c'est quand même
mieux d'aller au cinéma que de se
droguer peut sauver la vie
[Musique]
ce film assure un succès éternels o'mara
tamment dire ainsi que le prix de
l'entrée très accessible pour la
majorité des indiens pas étonnant alors
que le cinéma soit le loisir le plus
populaire l'idée de consommer et peu
importe la qualité ou les conditions par
exemple dans les quartiers les plus
pauvres de la ville pour seulement 15
roupies on peut assouvir ses fantasmes
et rêvait de belles histoires édifiantes
dans les vidéos par le veau
de petites salles étouffante fait de
quatre murs de béton de ben
inconfortables ou d'un côté il y a un
écran blanc avec lecteur dvd
rétroprojecteur et de l'autre la télé
essentiellement fréquenté par les
honneurs
[Musique]
à mumbai on peut aussi voir un film sur
la plage comme ça
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
le cinéma est partout indissociable du
quotidien il est l'opium d'un peuple qui
veut oublier la dureté de la vie et la
violence des contrastes sociaux pour
quelques heures seulement
[Musique]
le haut
après avoir écouté de la musique sur la
plage toute la nuit je quitte la plus
grande ville de l'inde et sa colossale
fabrique remuante
[Musique]
direction des vies la capitale ou même à
1400 kilomètres de là les airs de
bollywood retentissent encore et
toujours
après un long trajet de 16 heures je me
trouve dans le sud de la ville a hole
délit dans le marché de la chp at il y à
la plus célèbre fanfare de mariage de
tout le pays dia band existe depuis 1936
et c'est admin l'arrière petit fils du
créateur qui la dirige le rapport avec
le cinéma me direz vous et bien même le
jour de leur mariage les indiens ne
peuvent se passer des airs de bollywood
mes chansons de bollywood sont vraiment
importantes dans votre culture
ça fait vraiment partie de votre
quotidien comment expliquez vous ça
ses chansons sont tellement orientée
inspiré de la culture indienne
traditionnelle quelles sont elles mêmes
de vrie la tradition de notre pays et la
musique c'est aussi la tradition dans
les mariages alors les deux sont
indissociables
ses chansons sont universelles et se
trouve dans le coeur de chaque indien b
qu'ils soient petits grands vieux ou
jeunes c'est ça la clé du succès de
bollywood et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
qu'on fasse appel à césaire pour la
procession d'un mariage
ce soir on a un très grand mariage radja
stany il va y avoir une grande
procession dans la rue avec le marié qui
monte sur un cheval alors si vous voulez
vous êtes le bienvenu
comme ça vous pourrez voir et écouter
notre fanfare
[Musique]
le moment
hu
[Musique]
les airs la manière dont sont joués les
chansons les instrumentaux sont utilisés
tout ça est inspiré de notre culture
ancestrale est entièrement repris dans
les films à nous de l'adapter aussi à la
culture n'a point phare c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que les gens préfèrent qu'on
joue avec des instruments à vent comme
ça les airs de bollywood que nous
reprenons sont plus entraînants et
paraissent plus traditionnel
et cette fusion donne un vrai sens à la
procession du mariage
[Musique]
alors que le soleil se lève je quitte
delhi pour me rendre dans le gujarat
ahmedabad où le spectacle est aussi dans
la rue une façon peu commune de voir des
films en extérieur m'attend
[Musique]
ahmedabad est appelé par ses habitants
la ville poussiéreuse la sixième de
l'inde avec ses 5 millions d'habitants
autant un doux que musulman
parmi eux deux hommes de 55 ans qui à la
nuit tombée sillonne depuis une
trentaine d'années maintenant les rues
de la ville avec une énorme boîte
bizarre sur roulettes
exactement comme le firent au début du
20e siècle les frères lumière
c'est derrière cette porte que se cache
un cinéma unique celui de fille rose et
hanifi
[Musique]
des six est
la caverne d'ali baba c'est ici
[Musique]
hu
ah c'est le plus petit cinéma du monde
que j'ai jamais vu
ça fait plus de sens tant que notre
cinéma ambulant existe il n'y en a qu'un
au monde
avant il appartenait au père de fille
rose
il a acheté ce vieux projecteur patet
pour 25 roupies à l'époque il marche
toujours vous vous rendez compte
mon père l'a achetée dans les années 20
aux marchés des voleurs à mumbai il l'a
fait fonctionner toute sa vie
ça c'est mon père
cet article a été publié en 1964
j'avais cinq ans quand j'ai fait tourner
ce projecteur pour la première fois
c'était un film indien dans ce lac quand
mon père m'a vu il m'a frappée car
j'aurais pu mais les cro q t il était
occupé à autre chose alors j'ai mis la
bobine j'ai démarré le moteur et c'est
comme ça que j'ai commencé à marcher à
partir de cet instant j'ai toujours su
que je ferais ça toute ma vie depuis que
je suis petit ça me fascine
mais combien de personnes peuvent voir
un film ici
il ya 12 trous de chaque côté et deux
devant vingt-six personnes peuvent donc
voir un film est selon l'âge et la
taille il y à différentes places à
différentes hauteurs
je vais vous montrer vient par là toi si
toi là
ensuite on tire sur les manettes pour
ouvrir le trou et pour voir à
l'intérieur
tant que ce n'est pas ouvert personne ne
peut voir c'est une manière de contrôler
à ok et l'écran blanc et au fond sur la
porte en fait
et combien ça coûte une séance de cinéma
une roupie de roupies voire cinq copies
ça dépend c'est plus cher si le film
marche bien
[Musique]
ah mais c'est mécanique c'est génial
mais comment vous faites pour que ça
marche bien ce sont mes oreilles qui
guette le sont et qui me donne le rythme
[Musique]
ce que vous voyez c'est le plus jeune
fils me dit qu'on est ça s'appelle mais
là il date de 1948
on n'a pas que des films inédits on a
aussi des films américains comme spider
man 2 il a le monde perdu
ceux là sont tous doublés en nba
mais on en a aussi en anglais comme
james bond
et cela marche très bien aussi un
ladsous il ya une batterie regarde
[Musique]
si vous en aviez la possibilité vous
pourriez travailler ailleurs comme
projectionniste dans une salle de cinéma
par exemple
on nous a déjà proposé de travailler
dans des grands cinémas mais on a
toujours refusé on travaille ensemble
depuis toujours et pour nous il n'est
pas concevable de se séparer notre vie
c'est ça projetée du rêve dans les rues
vous savez c'est la crise dans le cinéma
il ya beaucoup de concurrence entre
l'arrivée des dvd les vidéos par laure
les salles où les séances sont à 50
roupies ont du mal à survivre un autre
échelle on arrive à vivre et si ça
marche pas ici on a la possibilité de se
déplacer ailleurs
nous on gagne entre 100 et 150 roupies
par jour
notre cinéma ambulant peut continuer à
fonctionner
et puis grâce à non il ya une ambiance
qu'on n'aura jamais dans une salle tout
le monde danse s'agite c'est vivant
bruyant mais c'est comme ça qu'il faut
vivre le cinéma
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
m
exact
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous savez on a une belle anecdote notre
charrette est un vrai lieu de
rendez-vous le garçon retrouve sa
bien-aimée ils regardent souvent le film
ensemble et c'est l'occasion pour eux de
se toucher la main ou échanger un billet
doux
et ça nous arrive que des coupes nous
arrêtent dans la rue pour nous dire que
c'est grâce à nous qu'ils sont tombés
amoureux
avant l'indépendance les femmes
n'avaient pas le droit d'aller dans les
salles de cinéma
seul moyen pour elle de voir des films
c'était notre ciném'ambulant
les femmes disaient alors c'est
formidable on a vu un film comme au
cinéma merci
[Musique]
quel est votre cinéma préférée
pourquoi vous aimez le braquage cinéma
le lumière ce qu'il y a que des bons
films et en plus c'est pas cher ça coûte
seulement de roupies vous aimez le
cinéma oui
qu'est-ce que vous aimez
le cinéma c'est marrant et les bagarres
c'est super drôle à regarder
si rose ça veut dire quoi prakash
vainqueur ça veut dire lumière
s'éteint à la fois hindous et musulmans
c'est un nom qui peut plaire à tout le
monde ça nous permet d'aller dans tous
les quartiers et que les gens de toutes
les religions voit les films que nous
projetons c'est une façon de dire que le
cinéma s'adresse à tout le monde il n'y
a pas de frontières c'est mon père qui
avait trouvé ce nom et je les gardais
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je serais bien resté ici à ahmedabad
avec les frères lumière indien
mais une autre histoire maths en 584
kilomètres plus loin
celle d'un homme qui souhaite des films
ça me rappelle le héros de soyez sympas
rembobinez de michel gondry qui fait des
parodies de films avec les moyens du
bord
c'est parti pour un long voyage de nuit
bienvenue à mal et garon à 280 km de
mumbai si bollywood se porte mal en ce
moment il ay ay si un jeune réalisateur
de 33 ans qui tente autre chose dans ce
village de 700 mille habitants c'est le
paradis des films à petit budget où les
stars sont artisans locaux femmes hommes
vieillards enfants vaches vélo et tout
ça c'est grâce à lui
chaque nation
quand il ne tourne pas les mariages du
point qu'il n'est pas dans sa boutique
de vêtements nassir et réalisateur
ici c'est un super héros
qu'est ce que tu fais je vais partir en
tournage
je suis en train de tourner superman à
malien ici c'est un fond vert contre
lequel superman va voler
ça c'est des flingues en plastique
des meneurs a été fait à partir de re de
[ __ ] de vélo tu fais quel genre de
film
qu'on m'aide et des comédies ni remake
quand je regarde un film sérieux une
finale ça me fait marrer et du coup j'ai
toujours envie d'en faire une comédie
un film d'action à une durée limitée et
alors qu'une comédie dure dans le temps
plein par exemple on se souvient tous
des films de charlie chaplin
[Musique]
voici mon equipe maïs c'est mon ami il a
fait l'un des rôles principaux dans mon
superman et lui c'est mon superman
comment tu t'appelles je m'appelle sa
fille
a tué un acteur professionnel ou tu fais
autre chose
non c'est mon hobby mon métier c'est y
seront
ce ne sont pas des acteurs
professionnels
[Musique]
ils trouvent ça uniquement par amitié
pour moi ils sont tous hyper content de
faire les acteurs
les films de nassir c'est beaucoup plus
que de simple remake son principe c'est
de prendre un film qui a du succès et de
mettre en avant les problèmes qu'il y a
dans notre village
par exemple lorsqu'il ya des crues dans
la rivière les enfants vont se baigner
et se noie
alors nasir cherche un moyen de dénoncer
ce problème en le mettant dans le film
pour que l'on puisse sensibiliser les
habitants et résoudre ce problème
superman on montre comment bien faire
les choses pour qu'il n'y a pas de
danger
par exemple si c'était spiderman qui
donnait des explications sur comment se
propage la grippe a et comment l'éviter
ça aurait certainement plus d'impact
[Musique]
quelle scène tu va tourner la
superman a repéré un gros voleurs au
score doit elle poursuivre
arrivé ici en volant et les enfants vont
courir devant lui
il me faut un vélo à il y en a un là
passez moi ton vélo
t'as pas de slip en dessous
[Musique]
qui a fait le costume
c'est moi
je les fais avec des scratchs pour qu'il
aille à tout le monde
[Musique]
oh
l émission chaque mission s'affiche sur
sa super remontent du coup il sait où il
doit voler
et vous les enfants venez là
mettez-vous devant lui
action
[Musique]
allez bouger plus la cab les gars
qu'on ait l'impression qu'ils veulent
je m'amuse beaucoup mais c'est du
travail pour nous on s'investit beaucoup
et en plus on devient de plus en plus
populaire
on a une vraie identité dans notre
village on adore ça et on existe grâce à
tout ce qu'on appelle ici c'est notre
les good and ou en multi on a réussi à
construire notre petit monde mobile
[Musique]
on a réussi à créer une association de
200 300 personnes et selon les rôles on
a différents acteurs
ce sont les mollets ou d'artistes
et ça c'est le plus vieux vous avez créé
une vraie industrie locale oui c'est ça
la malibu d'industrie il ya hollywood
bollywood et maintenant molly woods est
dans notre molly good cheikhna ciré
notre james cameron et en plus il donne
de l'espoir aux jeunes du village qui
veulent faire du cinéma
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]
oui
on doit les sentiers pas là pour la
toile en valais on peut y aller
je vous présente mes jumeaux ils ont
déjà vu des films
non ils sont encore petits
et c'est là que tu travailles
oui c'est ici que je monte mes films
et là tu vois je remplace le fonds vert
par un paysage
oui d'accord et une incruste les gens du
village qu'on a vu oui c'est ça
ça te coûte convient de faire un film
mon budget était de 15 mille roupies
pour mon premier film et pour superman
ça m'a coûté 100 mille roupies toute la
production comprise et ça te prend
combien de temps pour faire un film
trois mois et quand est ce que tu as eu
envie de faire des films en
avant j'avais un vidéo par l'or alors je
voyais plein de films les films
américains
c'est comme ça que je me suis forgé ma
culture et à force de voir des films
j'ai eu envie d'en faire moi même alors
j'ai pris ma petite caméra je me suis
mis à tourner et puis à monter mes films
et je suis heureux quand mes films ont
un impact
que les gens prennent conscience des
problèmes du village et qu'il ya des
changements de comportement le cinéma
doit servir à ça
on est où là
on est devant le cinéma maurane c'est
ici que sera projeté superman ces films
sont toujours projeté ici oui c'est ça
on y va oui à landi
et les villageois doivent payer pour
voir tes fils ou pas
oui et c'est 20 roupies la séance
il ya 900 places ici et chaque film
passe plusieurs fois par jour
des séances commencent soit trois heures
soit 6 heures
c'est génial pour toi alors quand on
filme et ici ah oui c'est vraiment bien
surtout que les films restent jusqu'à
deux semaines à la fiche
[Musique]
bonjour je suis rakesh le propriétaire
du cinéma de mal et garou
nassir c'est le seul gars qui a lancé
cette industrie du cinéma les gars ont à
chaque fois car de ses films est
présenté ici dans mon cinéma j'ai un
coup de téléphone des distributeurs de
mumbai il me demande si le film marche
bien et s'il investissait de l'argent
dans ses films est ce que ça leur
rapporterait de l'argent aussi
alors je leur réponds oui forcément
parce que la sir a besoin d'argent s'il
obtenait de l'argent des gros studios il
pourrait vraiment prendre de
l'importance dans l'industrie du cinéma
tu voudrais tourner des films à gros
budgets dans des gros studios où tu
préfère rester indépendant comme ça
non je préfère continuer comme ça avec
peu de moyens pourquoi est ce que toutes
mes ressources sont là j'ai mes amis qui
m'aident je suis livre ici avec tout le
monde qui m'aide
j'ai mon cinéma
mais tu préfère garder cette liberté
mais je ne veux pas aller à bollywood je
suis heureux à hollywood
chaque nasir est peut-être la solution
dont on aurait besoin bollywood pour se
renouveler et relancer son économie
[Musique]
vous voici à calcutta la quatrième ville
de l'inde avec ses 4 millions
d'habitants et ces fameux taxis
ambassador jaune poussin hautement
photogénique
[Musique]
c'est aussi la ville de cinéastes
indépendants
d'ailleurs dans le nord il ya un homme
qui fabrique ses propres films mais dans
un tout autre genre encore que nasir
[Musique]
l'homme en bleu c'est salim baba et pour
approvisionner son cinéma de quartier
toutes les semaines il va avec son sac
rouge en plastique à la main au marché
de margate un faire ses provisions
bonjour bonjour salim
j'ai quelques bons films cette semaine
doit jeter un oeil bah oui je suis venu
voir ce que tu avais de nouveau
je regarde les bobines j'essaye de voir
s'il y a des scènes intéressantes
il me faut une bonne séquence de combat
une autre avec des dialogues est très
important et une belle chanson puis je
regarde l'état général du film
ça fait 40 ans que j'achète mes films à
ces gens là
ils vendent des films en kilos ou alors
on peut acheter une boîte avec bobine
pour 15 roupies
ses bobines ce sont des chutes
ou bien des pellicules en mauvais état
destiné au rebut qu'il récupère auprès
des distributeurs
[Musique]
à
il est donc des films sont pas terribles
cette semaine les jeunes veulent voir
des nouveautés si je veux qu'on cinéma
marche bien je ne peux pas me permettre
de projeter trop vieux films bon allez
je te prends cela quand même
[Musique]
tu es notre unique client dans le
quartier à projeter des films comme ça
alors revenir la semaine prochaine et on
s'assure qu'on aura de meilleurs films
[Musique]
puis salim rentrer à la maison et fait
sa tambouille
je suis en train de regarder quelles
sont les scènes les plus intéressantes
je n'ai pas besoin de projeter le film
je récupère tous directement sur la
pellicule
et ensuite je vais découper tous les
passages intéressants
donc la up je vire ce morceau je coupe
un peu de ce côté un petit peu de
l'autre côté
voilà
et maintenant je vais pouvoir coller les
deux scènes qui m'intéresse ensemble
il faut bien aligner les deux morceaux
j'ai appris cette technique avec un
projectionniste
j'utilise du scotch normale
dans les cinémas il utilise un scotch
spécial
plus large mais moi je prends du normal
parce que c'est moins cher
vous voyez le scotch à boucher un trou
de la pellicule alors je vais le refaire
avec une lame de rasoir
en fait à partir de long métrage je
fabrique des résumés de films qui ne
dure que sept ou huit minutes et dans
lesquels on ne voit que les scènes
principales
c'est une sorte de bande annonce et
c'est ce que je projette dans mon cinéma
et les gens sont contents autant les
jeunes que les vieux en regardant ça ils
trouvent leur compte se distraient avant
d'aller au travail ou de rentrer chez
eux et en plus si vous allez dans une
salle ordinaire ça vous prend deux
heures de regarder un film et ça vous
coûte environ 15 roupies alors que moi
je vous montre tout en sept minutes pour
seulement une roupie
[Musique]
c'est ton fils oui c'est mon fils et ça
c'est un autre fils wayne lui aussi lui
et puis lui a mis quatre frères et fils
ils me suivent depuis qu'ils sont tout
petits
ils ont tous appris à faire marcher ce
vieux projecteur russe comme un père de
ses enfants mes quatre fils ont
développé un amour pour ce projecteur
ils ont le sentiment qu après mon départ
ils vont le garder et continuent à le
faire tourner et ça ça me touche
beaucoup
c'est pas qu'une question d'argent le
cinéma c'est notre passion à tous et ça
c'est notre histoire
et quand la nuit tombe la maison se
transforme en home cinéma et ses
projections en famille des oeuvres de
papa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
[Musique]
je
on
[Musique]
à
namasté hésite vous êtes le propriétaire
d'un travelling cinéma oui
c'est de plus en plus difficile d'en
trouver un
oui de nos jours ça ne courent plus les
rues alors qu'avant
pourquoi si serrar
d2 tout ça c'est à cause des dvd et le
toutes les chaînes de télé
ou est-ce que vous allez avec votre
cinéma en fait on va dans les villages
les plus reculés dans la forêt de
thunder ban
là où il n'ya pas de cinéma
et les gens attendent ça avec impatience
il ya plus de 3000 personnes qui se
déplacent à chaque fois pour voir le
film
et ça c'est le projecteur oui ça c'est
le projecteur
c'est un 35 mm ou et
[Musique]
on est super contents que cinéma soit là
il ne vient qu'au moment des festivités
ici on a hâte de voir un film d'action
sur grand écran
ici tout le monde attend ça avec
impatience
ça ne change j'espère que ce soir il y
aura plein de bagarre dans le film car
c'est ce que je peux faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
koné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
il
[Musique]
voyage à travers les toiles de l'inde se
termine avec le sentiment d'avoir été un
témoin privilégié celui d'instants
cinématographique de plus en plus rares
pas vous
[Musique]